[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
greégoryi est un jeune joueur de
Saint-Denis après 5 ans de pratique de
stage et d'engagement dans son sport il
se bat pour être en finale du tournoi
international de
badminton beaucoup
de de physique
de multivolant
ou
et depuis combien de temps tu fais du
badminton depuis 5 ans j'espère aller
loin dans le
bad je conseille de aux jeunes de faire
badminton parce que
c'est ça ser à se
défouler
à rencontrer
les d'autres personnes sport scolaire
numéro 1 en France le bad est joué par
tous les enfants scolarisés certains
d'entre eux s'engagent dans l'un des 14
clubs formateurs de lîle 40 % de jeunes
licenciés dont des sportif de haut
niveau soutenu par le Conseil
départemental au travers de leur
parcours d'excellence sportive le
tournoi
international c'est un tournoi sur
lequel on fait venir du monde on fait
venir des joueurs de
métropole mais dans le même temps on
ouvre ce tournoi au plus jeunes ce qui
leur permet de côtoyer les grands
champions les champions de France qui
viennent sur ce tournoi donc c'est pour
créer un peu d'émulation parmi les
jeunes c'est aussi un moyen de faire
venir des Mauriciens et donc là on a des
compétitions au plus haut niveau chez
les
[Musique]
jeunes après un bisou aux parents tel un
guerrier Julien s'engage sur le terrain
contre le meilleur joueur mauricien de
sa
catégorie
on a mis en place depuis plusieurs
années une école de badminton avec bah
une soixantaine si je me trompe pas de
de jeunes qui s'entraînent de du niveau
Minias c'est-à-dire vraiment la
découverte du badminton les premiers
gestes du badminton jusqu'à un niveau
élite c'est gratifiant de s'occuper des
jeunes de les voir évoluer de les voir
se développer et puis on part du
principe aussi que quand on leur offre
cette possibilité de se développer ben
derrière quand ils vont arriver chez les
seniors ben ce sont eux qui vont
rapporter les titres on aura eu
l'opportunité de leur faire pratiquer
leur sport dans un premier temps et puis
après de se développer en tant que
joueur et et pour ce pour les plus forts
bah de de gagner des titres par la suite
et de participer à des compétitions tes
que le le le tournoi international ici
en élite à côté c'est le même scénario
chez les filles réunion contre mauis se
battent pour la première place à Maurice
comme dans beaucoup de pays anglophones
le badminton est une institution
[Musique]
cette finale je l'ai vécu assez stressée
pour la finale tourno
international qu'est-ce que tu vas te
rappeler de ce moment tu gag oui je vais
me rappeler de ce moment
pouro c'est pas tout le temps qu'on
gagne un tournoi
international or se bat mais le match
est beaucoup plus dendu comme dans les
[Musique]
tribunes je pense que ça lui permett de
grandir de se débloquer un petit peu bon
il est c'est un grand timide comme le
papa comme la maman aussi et non non
mais c'est bien il y a que du stress
donc c'est la gestion du stress qu'il
faut qu'il faut mettre en avant pour les
enfants parce que plus tard
avenir il y aura que de ça ce tournoi
international de badminton donne de
l'ambition aux joueurs de la Réunion et
de la zone de quoi construire
[Musique]
l'avenir